Welcome from a very sunny and beautiful Aruba.
No, I'm kidding.
It's a pandemic.
I don't leave Massachusetts right now, but
there is a lot to talk about.
Last week, I did a story called We Owe the
World an Apology and an Explanation.
And that story was really focused on having
to sort of make good with the world for the
fact that more than 60 million Americans voted
for Donald Trump in 2016.
And in so doing, unleashed absolutely unconscionable
destruction upon the world.
That was last week.
And the focus was mostly the micro while touching
on some of the big areas where the United
States has been really a drag on the world
under Donald Trump.
So we talked about climate change.
Of course, we talked about naturally.
How could I not mention our disastrous response
to coronavirus?
But there's an entire sort of other story
to tell about the United States under Trump,
which is less about Trump per say and more
about the way in which our status quo has
been exposed as dangerously fragile in so
many ways, which is something that even people
who are not necessarily Trump ists have been
sometimes hesitant to really consider as seriously
as as we should.
And of course, the virus itself has exposed
a lot of fragility.
A lot of jobs that seemed rock solid were
not really Robbs rock solid.
Entire industries, quite frankly, were not
as solid as we thought.
Our supply chains, we figured out very quickly,
are very fragile, the medical system.
Of course, that's useful to think about.
But there is a way more sort of pernicious
fragility that has been exposed, including,
for example, our alliances with other countries
around the world.
This is not corona virus specifically now.
This is what I'd call a sort of trump fragility
allies that we felt were rock solid.
Our primary important allies were very quickly,
as soon as the United States was challenged
and was no longer a reliable, predictable
partner.
And instead, we became this sort of erratic,
counterproductive fiasco.
Many of our allies abandoned us.
Now, they didn't do it in a way where they
would now be considered adversaries, certainly
not, but to different degrees in in their
own ways.
We saw what we thought were very solid alliances
be exposed as extremely fragile very quickly.
Germany, France and Canada, for example, realized
we can't deal with Trump like an adult.
We're actually better off without the American
president in the room at all when we're having
certain conversations.
That's embarrassing and that's bad for us
long term.
Now, I don't necessarily want to go directly
into a sort of geopolitics game theory type
of analysis, but it is kind of hard to avoid
when you look at what's going on around the
world, because when you look at the superpowers
of the world, U.S., Russia and China, and
you think about the last four years, it's
not looking particularly good for the United
States.
This may not be your top priority, but if
you concede that the most likely superpower
in the world is likely to be either the U.S.,
China or Russia for some time, a United States
that's increasingly isolated and losing allies
is bad.
It's bad for Americans as China gains leverage
in the increasingly failed trade war that
Donald Trump has been waging against them.
As Russia continues to benefit from the destabilization
and the lack of credibility of American democracy
partially at their own doing, of course, we
suffer.
There's a very good article in Rolling Stone
from this weekend by Wade Davis called The
Unraveling of America, and it focuses on this
debasement of America in the context of Corona
virus.
The article is great, but almost every argument
that Wade Davis makes and he makes the arguments
well with respect to Corona virus, we could
actually apply in the United States more broadly.
I'll give you an example.
Davis says in this article, which you should
read in its entirety.
The American handling of Corona virus has
called into question the idea of American
exceptionalism.
I would go further.
Our failed response to Corona virus has confirmed
that the idea of American exceptionalism was
but a shiny Band-Aid covering up serious injuries.
It exposed many of the cultural failings that
Corona virus has made clear.
The lack of our ability to really come together
as a country to do what just needs to be done,
even if it's difficult for the betterment
of humanity.
The financial fragility has been exposed.
Wade Daviss article reminds us that almost
every empire has fallen the ends of.
Empires are rarely anticipated and they often
take a while.
But you don't notice that the failing empire
is failing.
Until you look back later, it's the United
States this time that needs the world's help,
as just about every other country has better
dealt with coronavirus than we have.
So what is it that hurt us?
Yeah, you know, of course, Trump's response
was a disaster, but there's more.
There's really cultural problems.
Is it too much individualism in the United
States?
Is it a lack of education or of good enough
education?
Delusions of grandeur.
All of the above.
Yeah, probably some component of all of those.
So I encourage you to check out the piece
in Rolling Stone.
And if we step back for a moment, from the
sort of day to day of the Trump administration,
what has become clear is that beyond Donald
Trump himself, this type of way of running
the country is not going to allow us to solve
the big problems that we're facing.
So in no particular order, step back from
Corona virus a little bit.
If you think about climate change, if you
think about getting everybody health care,
if you think about ending optional poverty
and hunger, which are optional right now,
I mean, it's just we've just not decided to
fix them.
But hunger and homelessness are optional at
this point in time, creating government that
is not crony a stick and corrupt.
Big, big things.
None of those problems are going to even be
seriously explored from the standpoint of
solutions under an administration like the
one we have.
It's not just the day to day pedestrian xenophobia
that's an afterthought, but it's the pseudo
intellectual ism, the anti intellectual ism,
the hyper nationalism, the intellectual isolationism.
That's when you look at how every other country
realizes this is a time to trust science and
doctors and we are isolated intellectually
or a..
Intellectually, where you have people thing.
Foushee and Bill Gates are the enemies here.
That's not suited for the 21st century and
beyond.
And it's hurting us now visibly with corona
virus.
But it's more about the list of problems we
won't be able to solve if this is how the
United States operates more broadly.
Now, I know many of you will say, well, OK,
63 million people voted for this administration,
65, 66 voted against it for Hillary Clinton,
that this is not about the electoral politics.
This is about a realization of what is the
path forward for humans with something that
is very antiquated.
And by the way, when I say antiquated, I'm
more than willing to entertain the argument
that in times past this type of mentality
made more sense.
I'm sensitive to the idea that an early humanity,
many of the traits that now are a problem
were adaptive from an evolutionary standpoint,
favoring these ideas of, you know, hypermasculine,
alpha, male, physical violence, individualism
for yourself or your small group isolationism.
There was a time in human history where that
made sense, and that was a totally reasonable
thing to think about.
But it doesn't make sense now.
And the people sticking to those ideas, Díaz,
are quite literally stuck in the past when
we say conservatism.
What we're talking about is trying to conserve
a way of life from the past merely because
it's what we used to do.
Even if it doesn't make any sense now or in
the future.
And that's exactly where we are today.
A lot to think about when you bring it back
to well.
We're less than three months from an important
election.
And today I'm going to be outlining some of
the big differences between the options that
we have in November, differences that maybe
are not the ones that are getting the most
attention.